hey everyone this is kevin from the
chester website comm and today we're
going to be looking at the nice little
bit offense against the pawn opening of
d4 from white and that's the Grune fell
defense let's go ahead and get into it
starts with pawn to d4 black knight to
f6 development move aiming at the center
white continuing with his pawns to c4
trying to gain center control black
playing pawn to g6 getting ready to
fianchetto as bishop to the g7 square
white playing Knight to c3 development
of move and at the same time putting
pressure on the center and from here
black going to play pawn to d5 and this
is the situation we're going to look at
the wrap this video and this is the
Grune failed defense and white has a few
options here and the first one we're
going to look at is the main line and
that's the exchange variation and one of
the key things that you look at
throughout the Greenfeld offenses white
really has to pay a lot of attention to
defending this Center black is going to
play a hyper modern offense meaning that
he's going to give up senator control to
white and why it's going to control the
center with his pawns Black's not going
to try to attack the center with his
pawns instead he's going to try to
attack the center with all his minor
pieces and major pieces aimed at the
center of the board
so he's going to give up the center to
bolt to white with his pawns in exchange
he's going to attack the center so why
it's going to have to be on the defense
and hold on in this case it's going to
be the default con and we'll look at
that here in a minute but why it's going
to have to play very defensively to try
to hold on to the center that black is
going to give white in the beginning and
then we'll look at a few variations
where white can actually avoid the main
line and get into more aggressive lines
if he doesn't like to play a defensive
style from white soap
we'll go ahead and continue and first
look at the main line and that's with
white taking on d5 with this pawn and
blacks going to recapture with this
Knight and whites going to bring his
pawn down to e4 attacking this knight on
d4 forcing its movement at the same time
getting a nice square for his pawn on e4
white has very good center control with
his pawns as you can see black does not
blacks going to continue take up this
knight on c3 and White's going to take
with his pawn on c3 as you can already
tell black has no pieces really aimed at
the center besides his Queen on d8 aimed
at this d4 square this d4 square is
going to be a very important square that
we'll see but you can see blacks already
conceded the center of the board he's
not even trying right now to gain
control the center with his pawns
instead he's going to try to use his
minor pieces and he's going to start out
with his Bishop to g7 fianchetto is
Bishop to g7 Square and from here
White's going to bring his Bishop to c4
now a few times you will see Knight
bring his excuse me white bring his
knight to f3 but a lot of times I think
this is the wrong move
because Farah did play this and so it's
really hard to say that it's the
incorrect play if he can play it but I
don't play life Kasparov he's a little
better than I am and from here I think
after Bishop to g4 pinning this Knight
down that's just too much pressure I
think added on the center I think
White's going to play a much better game
if he just brings his bishop to the c-4
square and that is the mainlines we're
going to just continue with Bishop to c4
adding pressure on the center and from
here blacks going to counter King side
this Bishop here with attacking this f7
Square is a very key weakness for black
and so blacks going to go ahead and put
his king and safety castling kingside
and from here what's going to bring his
Knight to e2 and this is a much safer
Square both is knight on f3 and knight
on each who are both going to
in this pawn on d4 which is what we need
the knight to do but now if we bring our
Bishop to g4 we can no longer pin this
knight down to the Queen the white pawn
can just come to f3 so you're not going
to see Bishop come out and do that
instead you'll see that black play a
move more common of pawn to c5 and what
this does is adds a lot of pressure to
this d4 square as you can see we've
already started to put a lot of pressure
on this pawn here on d4 we have our
bishop we have our pawn and we have our
Queen all attacking this pawn on d4 now
from here play continues with white
castling and then Black's going to
develop his Knight to c6 at the same
time putting another attacker on this d4
pawn from here you may see play continue
with Bishop to e3 adding another
defender on the d4 pawn and from here
the Queen's going to come to c7 and what
this does if you've seen some of the
other videos it indirectly attacks this
bishop on c4 so from here a lot of times
you'll see white bring his knight -
excuse me his rook to c1 he's indirectly
defending this bishop on c4
once these pawns are exchanged then the
rook now is going to defend this bishop
on c4 so that's why you see those moves
in the mainline and from here you'll see
rook to d8 putting even more pressure on
this pawn and from here you may even see
white continue to add pressure on the d4
pawn by bringing his rook on f1 to d1
and this is the main variation you will
see a few variations in the exchange
variation that we talked about the very
beginning when the pawn takes on d5 and
as you can tell black does not have
sender control but all his pieces are
aiming at the center trying to undermine
white sender control the pawns why it's
going to have to play very smart and
very defensively to hold on to this
advantage so let's go ahead and take a
look at a few other variations that you
will see often we'll go and get into
again d4 Grune fell defense and after d4
white does not have to capture here one
of the more common moves that you will
see is Bishop to f4 and this is a move
that I like myself it it keeps white
playing an aggressive game and at the
same time it still adds a lot of
pressure to the center if flexing that
lets you take the center you might as
well take it and then just play
accordingly depending on how you want
the game to go so from here you'll see
black castle after you fiend kiddoes his
Bishop to g7 and from here there's a few
moves but I like white playing pawn to
e3 getting ready for his bishop to come
into the game defending this pawn on c4
now from here a lot of times you'll see
pawn to c5 but you may not see pawn to
c5 right away and it's very interesting
how it looks a lot of players look at
this is the Grune fel game but I like to
look at it as just a pawn loss if you
see players after pawn to e3 Castle
kingside before they play c5 then from
here after the exchange why it's going
to be up a pawn now it's called a gambit
but I actually just think that White's
better and he's up in material and it'll
look like this after pawn takes on d5
and Knight takes
and the white knight takes and the queen
takes then the bishop can take on c7 and
this is why more times than not you'll
see this pawn to c5 instead of castling
kingside first so if you do see castle
on the Queen side first is the Grune
felt gambit but if you're playing white
and you do see this just go ahead and
take the gambit and go ahead and take
this pawn on c7 but more times than not
you're going to see the player play his
pawn to c5 first and you'll do this
because from here you'll see pawn takes
on D excuse me on c5 and from here the
Queen's going to come to a5 from Queen
he's pinning down this knife and I can't
go anywhere is going to get his queen
involved on this c5 pawn after he
captures so that's one thing you will
see let's go and take a look at one
other example that you may see after
here
bless example we're going to look at is
the Russian variation and it's probably
the most aggressive from white so if
you're playing white and you see you do
see the green fell defense and you still
want to keep that aggressive nature in
you then I suggest the Russian variation
because it is very aggressive from white
it gets the Queen involved early and
therefore you're going to be putting a
lot of pressure on black and it
continues with the moves Knight to f3
instead of capturing at the beginning or
trying to gain center control with your
Bishop you're instead going to bring
your knight to f3 if he brings his
Bishop into the act your that's not
going to be pinned down so more times
than not you're not going to see the
bishop come out right away instead more
times than that you'll see the bishop
being ketta to g7 and from here the
Queen can now come to b3 and this is the
aggressive move that we're talking about
here we're pretty much forcing black to
capture on c4 and after he captures and
we recapture with our queen on c4
you can already tell that we don't quite
have the same presence in the middle
with our pawns as we did in the exchange
variation but at the same time we do
still have a very good center control we
have good center control with our
Knights we have a good pawn placed on d4
and our Queens very active now a lot of
times black will try to chase our coin
around but this is why this is the more
aggressive variation so for those white
players that are aggressive keep in mind
this is an option for if you want to
avoid the exchange variation or bring
your Bishop to f4 which is very popular
and I like so this is the groom fel
defense take a look at it play around
with it let me know what you think
everyone thanks for watching
if you haven't already please subscribe
if you haven't checked out the website
please do WWH s website com let me know
what you think and I'll see you guys
next video thanks for watching everybody